[Music]
good morning ladies and gentlemen we're
ready to start the morning session and I
couldn't think of a better eye opener
than the pioneer of digital convergence
Nicholas Negroponte II as you well know
he is director of the world-famous and
still unique interdisciplinary Media Lab
here at MIT which just has been
celebrating 10 years of accomplishment
with a big bash his hit book being
digital and his monthly columns in Wired
are helping to educate the lay public
about the all-important paradigm shift
that is happening because of digital
convergence and I personally am very
glad that he's contributing his atoms
rather than his bits here today Nicholas
keep forgetting podiums have these
slopes to them
[Music]
am i live we're now live okay as Andy
mentioned the media live just celebrated
its 10th anniversary which is not
particularly important but what's
happened is that when you make an event
of that scale we invite all of the sort
of consortium that formed parts of the
laboratory and all of the various groups
so this has not been one day this has
been a bonanza of meetings that started
Sunday night and so you get the dregs
this morning I'm sorry to say I will do
my best
and I may I don't know if anybody
attended the the 10th but I may repeat
some of the stories I even told at the
beginning of it about three years ago I
became involved with Wired magazine and
I became involved in a very odd way it
wasn't my idea I mean it was Louis
Rosetta's and Jane Metcalf's
and but nobody would fund them none of
the big media tycoons or none of the VCS
would fund them and I agreed to fund
them and to protect my investment I
wrote the back page I said I'll write
the back page too so if it this thing
goes down the tubes at least I'll client
you know I'll be part of it going down
the tubes and if it's a success then let
me be part of that too but I would
invest more than money I'd invest some
energy and about a year and a half ago
maybe it's a little more a little less I
learned something
absolutely astonishing at least it
really touched me and that was that the
largest number of subscribers were kids
buying wired for their parents for
Christmas okay and that touched me
actually because it was basically kids
saying mom and dad this is about me and
here's her Christmas present now when I
sort of heard that and it was about the
18th issue I said well maybe the thing
to do is to take
the 18 back pages and make them into a
book for mom and dad which of course is
awfully naive because I let you just
take the 18 stories and you staple them
together and you send them back to the
publisher and they put a cover on it it
was not that at all it was basically
writing something all over again but in
the process of doing it I ran across and
I'm not even sure when and how but sort
of bumped into the the idea of thinking
about the world in terms of bits and
atoms and using that perspective and
that if you looked at something as we
normally do in fact as laws are created
and so on they're usually based on atoms
things that we can touch and feel and
have weight mass and so on and yet that
the world of bits was really quite
different and even though in my
experience at MIT in computer science
either formally or informally we hadn't
really thought very much about the fact
that bits didn't have size weight color
mass and more or less traveled at the
speed of light and that that this was
really a very kind of interesting
dichotomy and there are two stories that
I'm very fond of saying one will touch
your your hearts I think quite directly
others more related to
telecommunications but think of some of
the things that have happened in the
past ten years and I'm gonna my first
example would be in 1983 when judge
Greene broke up the telephone company he
told the are box the regional Bell
operating companies he said you are not
allowed in the information business now
think of that remark is actually a very
strange remark because every single one
of the regional Bell operating country
companies in this country produces
yellow pages and those yellow pages in
every case all seven is the highest
margin business that any of them run
it's not the biggest cash generator okay
but in just in terms of margins they're
almost obscene okay
so the yellow pages which was certainly
the information business was was fair
game they could do that so if you think
of what judge green was saying in terms
of bits and atoms what he was basically
saying was it's absolutely okay to more
or less D foliate to squeeze ink on dead
trees perhaps even to use child labor to
hurl these these huge you know chunky
books over the transoms of American
doorsteps but that it was utterly
illegal and against the law
to transmit a node return no deposits
ecologically sound bit at the speed of
light into the home so that I mean if
you really looked at in terms of bits
and atoms it was the most absurd
position that he was taking in 1983 and
of course it took over ten years to even
start to change it there's some people
in this room who are actively involved
in digital libraries and you look at
digital libraries and you ask yourself
why do library libraries or physical
libraries why do they work and one of
the reasons they work is absolutely I
mean it's almost completely based on
atoms the reason a library works today
is that I take my atoms down to the
library some of us have a few too many
of them when I get there
let's presume I'm allowed in the stacks
and I borrow the book something that
people don't tell you about atoms is
that when you borrow an atom
there's no atom left okay's empty space
so you take the book off you read it for
a week you bring it back and
miraculously somebody borrows it again
you bring it back miraculously somebody
borrows it again a week later and at the
end of that little unlikely episode 52
people have read that book in one year
now as some of you were doing and people
that we all know when you try when you
take that model and you
the digital library and you turn it into
bits what happens first of all you don't
have to take your atoms down there and
second of all and again we're never told
this okay cuz it's so obvious when you
borrow a bit there's always a bit left
so lo and behold 20 million people when
theory can borrow the same bit and we
violated copyright law in any country
that has it and certainly violated a
sense of intellectual property now my
point is is really quite simple the
point is if you if you look at some very
very sort of and again they're very
simple observations and you think of
them in terms of bits and atoms and I'll
get back to this afterwards it really is
a very very different perspective and so
I started down this this path to to do
that and discovered in the process that
what was going on in the United States
in general in the past sort of twelve
months really was much more dramatic
than even the most sort of most extreme
and most sort of wild predictions we're
all sort of falling short let me give
you an example
the official statistic is that forty
five to fifty five percent of all new
personal computers are going into the
American home and it depends who you
speak to I mean in tell will tell you
it's fifty something someone else said
but the range is between 45 and 50
percent and they think boy isn't that a
big number I mean it's a very big number
well the real number is more like
seventy five percent and the reason it's
75 percent is for a reason that that is
obvious again but nobody knows how to
count it and that is that almost every
single corporation in the United States
when they look at somebody's desktop and
I say upgrade your 386 to a Pentium or
something and they're hey what do they
say they say take the old one home or
they say why don't you buy a laptop
and that way you can go back and forth
between work and home so it turns out
that today 50% of black teenagers have
personal computers at home seventy-five
percent of all teenagers have computers
at home and the the the none of us even
those who were you know considered nuts
in their speculations would have ever
have predicted that kind of rate of
change partly because and this again is
is you know speculation on my part but I
think part of it is our just our body
clocks aren't exponentially sensitive
we're not sensitive to things that
happen exponentially we don't know how
to understand them yes we all can plot
things on log log paper but we we don't
understand things that happen webs
doubling every fifty days now we don't
know what that means we don't understand
what doubling every 50 days means but we
do understand it turns out that today
roughly there's a new there's a new
homepage every five seconds that we can
understand we can say aha yes that's
prime minister but the doubling part we
really don't understand so in parallel
again the kids subscribing you know for
their parents there was this other
phenomenon of sort of exponential growth
but in a very very odd demographic in
the United States right now if you look
at the the population and you find that
they're basically no fifteen-year-old
Americans that are digitally illiterate
okay now if I count Nintendo and Sega
that's a hundred percent true and if you
pull the Nintendo and say go out of the
question out of the equation
it's still roughly you know probably 90%
true or at least it's so true that it's
it's as good as a hundred percent and
then what happens it's really very odd
it's a it's a period in time that won't
last long but it's a very odd phenomenon
the highest percentage of people getting
online as a percent of their age group
are the elderly 55 years old and up
right now
and that really is true so what do you
have you got this big swell that moves
very quickly anybody's apparent in this
room knows how fast that moves so you've
got this big swell here at the sort of
lower end you then got this other swell
at at the other at least not as big but
at least growing very very rapidly and
what you have in the middle is what I
call the digital homeless and the
digital homeless who are they they're
affluent
they're literate well-educated and it's
people who have the one thing that the
other two groups are sorry missing the
one thing that the other two groups have
in spades and that is time they don't
have time they're just too busy or and
they're not like ourselves sort of in
the field so you you get this very odd
sort of distribution right now which
makes and it's the demographics at least
the United States right now is is indeed
very very peculiar it's not it's not
normal at all and probably in four years
at law it'll all shift over but for the
moment it really is a very special
condition which in my opinion leads to a
lot of the I don't want to call them
problems because they haven't come up as
problems yet necessarily but leads to a
lot of kind of the misunderstanding
because that same digitally homeless
group tend to be the people who are
making laws and decisions and run
companies and do all sorts of things so
it's in some sense the the intellectual
and management power of the United
States tends to occupy that space in the
middle so again I started sort of
thinking about it and ran sort of after
sort of pushing the book being digital
out I realized when I finally shared the
podium in Los Angeles with Don Rickles
and David Koresh's mother I said you
know boy yes you know this really is
computing maybe it's becoming you know
the popular thing and it was a very odd
experience and I don't recommend it and
certainly don't know don't intend to do
actually I also shared the podium was
really bizarre shared the podium with a
four-legged llama not sure why and then
I shared the podium on another occasion
with Marteen Marteen was a man who'd
changed his sex to a woman in order to
have a lesbian relationship with his
wife while they brought up the four
children you know so that was also part
of you know this that was considered on
the same wavelength as being digital and
so it was it was an odd experience for
me but in doing that the one of the
things that that happened to me was when
I was in Michigan you know you sign your
life away for two weeks and sort of the
publisher then like almost puts you on a
sort of a orbit for that two weeks and I
happen to be in Michigan in February the
day after this kid Jake Baker was was
arrested for posting his message on
whatever it was all thought sex thought
bestiality or something and I don't know
if you remember the story but what he
had done is he had written this story
posted it I forget how many days it
lived out there and a guy in Moscow okay
just cute detail logged in to whatever
it was all thought sex dog bestiality
and was offended now you know digest
that for a second you know my image my
image is walking down a street in
Amsterdam to passing what might have
been a storefront selling I don't know
god knows what but the glass has been
painted over in black and it says that
the giant orange letters sex shop and
dangling from the front door or an
inflated prophylactics and you go
through into the door you're not going
to get
I mean you've made a pretty fundamental
decision when you go through that door
and this Russian in my opinion made that
same decision read it got offended and
happened to be and again I don't know
how many people know the exact story but
happened to be an alumnus of the
University of Michigan and he complained
I don't know if it was to the Alumni
Office or the president's office but he
complained and lo and behold at eleven
o'clock at night the sheriff arrests
Jake Baker confiscates his reading
glasses okay I'm dead serious
okay plop him in jail without bail okay
without bail
and for those of you know the story the
part that I've left out is that he had
actually used a real person's name and
there was some people claiming that I
don't know it was at any rate I don't
even want to try and imagine what the
case is because it's with the out
without bail part that that got me
because I didn't think we did that in
the United States and there he sat for
over 30 days without bail and the reason
I knew about is because his mother and
stepfather he came to see me and asked
if I could help get him out of jail and
he did indeed finally get out on bail
and I don't know what effect I had but
at any rate he got out on bail and when
it hit the courts in June it was
dismissed the case was dismissed as
frivolous on behalf on that the
government's case was frivolous that it
was fiction and it didn't even it didn't
even get didn't get beyond that point it
was just dismissed and when you see
something like that happen it and again
I'm certainly not a lawyer but it just
it seems to me that the law is is by
definition a reactive phenomenon and
when it reacts sort of so
thirdly sort of a little bit like a
floppy flopping sort of dying fish on a
dock you know something I think
something rather big it's sort of like
an early warning system just again it's
another story I'm fond of telling
happened a little bit before the Jake
Baker incident and less people knew
about it at least the first part of it a
lot of people knew about the second part
what happened was I think it was in the
middle of January a cleric in Pakistan
actually asked officially that the
United States extradite Madonna and
Michael Jackson to stand trial for
having violated fundamentalist Islamic
law and this did not this did not get
the front page of any paper in fact I'm
not even sure the State Department
responded officially and most people
sort of just laughed at all but almost
at exactly the same time a couple whose
name I can't remember in cupertino were
actually the neighboring town had some
bits on their computer that were
absolutely legal by Cupertino sort of
standards and legal by California law
and legal by outside of that and some
guy in Tennessee logs in to that's gonna
have sucks the bits over to Tennessee
doesn't like what he sees on his screen
calls his Sheriff the sheriff doesn't
like what he sees on the screen the
sheriff of in Tennessee calls the
sheriff in Cupertino
they not only arrest the people they
extradite them to Tennessee okay we
didn't do this with Michael Jackson and
Madonna and a lot of parents white of
wish we had at any rate there he is he
is put on trial found guilty and is
guilty today I mean they're appealing
but it's stupid and you say wait a
moment what's going on and what's going
on is is in my opinion just something
very simple but this is a big one and we
don't understand it
and that the bits and atoms issue is in
fact you know people will say it's all
hype okay yes there's a lot of hype but
it is wild understatement I think what's
going on right now is the tip of an
iceberg that in the next year or so when
you get things like untraceable digital
cash when you get some of the
intellectual property issues and all of
these things that start to come up which
will all surface in the next 12 months
it's sort of a big way I think it's a
very I think it's it's a non-trivial
period the fact that it's the 50th
anniversary that created this event it's
the 50th anniversary also this year of
Arthur Clarke's famous paper on
satellites and I mean there's a lot of
sort of 50th sits the 50th anniversary
of the UN that seemed to be a lot of
50th but you know what's gonna happen in
the 51st year is gonna be pretty
dramatic of all of those sort of events
and I think it's I think it's a really
big deal I think we've all
underestimated it okay every single one
of us and most a lot of people in this
room were very much part of things like
the internet and things like the world
wide web and multimedia and hypertext my
god I mean what a group I mean of all
the people but I think it's fair to say
that every single person in this room
okay underestimated it we didn't think
it would be as big as it's turned out
and and again I think if you if you just
try to understand what it'll do to
electronic commerce and so on some of us
use big words and strong voices and
parade with great energy and can say
these here but deep down in your hearts
I think a lot of you including myself we
don't really believe that it's as big as
it probably is and and I think that's
quite important and you know again I'm
not sure a symposium like this is is the
one that's going to change that
I've Andy has asked me to sort of end
five minutes early because there's some
group photograph that has to be taken
and I'm sort of sort of held I've got a
deadline at the other end and I want to
leave time for questions so I'm going to
use about five or ten more minutes and
sort of sort of tell you where I think
again we whatever that means the sort of
what the media labs been doing since we
did celebrate our tent and it's kind of
a soul-searching phenomenon sort of what
we think we did where we think we're
going because for the very same reason
that that bits are sort of you know
weightless colourless sizeless travel at
the speed of light
we can't experience some bits are not
something that humans can experience in
any way until they're turned back into
atoms now yes maybe we can start wiring
ourselves in the future but for the time
being we really have to turn them back
into atoms and the art of turning atoms
into bits and bits into atoms has in
some sense been oh I would have never
said it this way has been what I've
spent my career doing it's what people
like Andy started thirty years ago
Alan did 2530 years ago I mean some of
us know I mean there's just many people
in this room who were doing that though
I don't think we thought of it in those
exact terms one of the things that
happened in the late 70s is that a few
people and it wasn't consider was sort
of considered sissie computer science at
the time felt that that that just wasn't
a sensory richness to this sort of bits
to atoms conversion and that may be the
right thing to do is to look because as
the kind of jingle at the Media Lab is
bits are bits and there's no such thing
as video or audio or data and some of
you they're all sort of they're all bits
and that you should get into the sort of
so called multimedia environment etc and
kind of sorts of things that we've done
what's happening now is that that
agendas over industries taken at least
the bits into the atom side of it the
you know the richness of the output of
most computers is is by no means a done
deal but it's at least compared to ten
years ago quite extraordinary the
reverse is still a mess I mean my god I
mean the path back in is in fact in my
opinion is as decrepit as it was 20
years ago but so that's obviously on the
agenda for the next decade but we have
always and we again I'll speak for you
know the 300 people at the Media Lab
vaguely is that we've always thought of
turning the bits into atoms in order to
sort of experience the bits and so the
atoms were there just because that's
what you see and it's the phosphorous
that glow or you you wiggle a little
sort of air and you make sound and so on
but the pervasiveness of the atoms was
not particularly important and that's
why sort of as part of our agenda over
the next decade we've started this thing
called things that think because you
know there is now a new space that has
to do with the personality of objects
and that personality comes from thinking
and linking and so on and so forth and
we'll certainly be for us a major agenda
and one of the fact there's a very big
consortium that was launched or was
announced on Tuesday which has a lot of
for us new companies very fact it's
rather exciting because it's companies
like Nike sneaker and or Nike sort of
the company make a lot of other things
other than sneakers Federal Express
steel case furniture and it's a whole
different world for us and what they
have in common is that they make things
but they don't talk to each other
and one of the things we have started
doing is is to is to work more
extensively because people had been
doing this for a long time on wearable
computing and it turns out that that
some of the faculty have discovered that
you really can ship a hundred thousand
bits per second through the body using
the body basically as a bus and it's a
whole new definition I guess of a
backplane and and what you really what
you can what you could what that does is
that it makes if you shake hands with
somebody you really can exchange one
hundred thousand bits per second so
maybe in the ten years from now the next
conference you go to you just shake
hands with everybody and then go home
and print out all the calling cards or
you might go to a phone booth and pick
up a handset and just in the few seconds
it takes to get that handset off the
hook to your ear you have downloaded a
hundred thousand bits per second for the
three seconds and put in all of your
speech and voice patterns and everything
so you then all of a sudden the handset
is it's much easier for it to do the
speech recognition etc and it's probably
actually a very you know again and the
things that think if your body can
actually be you know can radiate that
account of you know both radiate and
take in the amount of bits it's probably
a pretty interesting thing to be working
on so those are the kinds of things that
I think we'll be doing over the next
decade and what it all gets down to and
this is this is I guess sort of the
right place to end is that that
computing really is not about computers
anymore okay and if you think it is
you're in the wrong field ok Computing's
about life and it really has left the
desktop it's left a lot of the things
that we that we have you know taken for
granted and
that's sort of a hard thing to accept
but I think it's important that in fact
think it's very important that we
recognize that because otherwise you're
just gonna you know just be scaling up
that kind of junk sitting on the table
and that's not what it's about and I
think it's a very very big you know I
think it's a it's time that we recognize
that and having said that I'm gonna
leave the next ten minutes for questions
and then we break for four and even if
there's no questions I'll ask a question
of myself so don't worry but oh you have
to go to the mic okay
okay sorry I didn't know that protocol
yeah also I'm Michael Lesk
one of my problems with all these
intelligent objects is that they argue
with each other about control I heard a
wonderful talk from a gentleman at
Phillips who said that well between the
set-top box makers and the TV set makers
and even the remote control makers
everybody wants their box to be
intelligent and in control and all the
other boxes to be dumb peripherals and I
got no sense and I in general have no
sense that we're learning how to solve
the social problem of persuading all
these companies that they should be
making cooperating boxes and I just
don't know what we do about that well
in our sort of image of things that sink
we don't think too much about boxes okay
as soon as you say the word box it seems
to me a giveaway that you have already
got a computing engine of some sort that
is expected to do something that is
already of a digital nature for us we're
thinking in terms of door knobs hinges
paint you know thumb tacks nails you
know it's a much it's it's it's like
sort of a very fine-grained parallel
processor versus you know big chunky
things because a set-top box and a TV
set are again in that family and the
set-top box made it makers are gonna be
history for another reason so we can
dismiss them and they're gonna evaporate
the TV manufacturers are gonna be
history for yet another reason so I
don't care about them too much but I do
care about the people who make toasters
and people who make microwave ovens and
so on and so forth the REIT because
again the personality of an object take
a doorknob it would not be very
difficult to get people to sort of
appreciate the fact that if the doorknob
could see could listen you know could
recognize burglars could recognize the
Federal Express man and sign for you
could sort of open the door when you're
coming in with packages and so on that
that might be kind of enhancing the
behavior and again the personality of
the doorknob the likelihood of that
happening in the doorknob is quite small
okay right at least for the next few
years and even if it could happen in the
doorknob you don't want to replicate it
in all doorknobs necessarily so there's
gonna have to be and this is where
you're dead on it's got to be a lot of
linking going on and these manufacturers
are gonna have to talk to each other but
it's not so much john malone talking to
apple computer talking to zenith
it really is Yale lock talking to I
don't know
Stanly something-or-other talking to
whoever makes carpet etc and I think
it's a different grain yes
with respect to the horror stories you
just told about people getting arrested
and extradited and stuff do you think
that would you consider that to be a
reason not to go online in the first
place you're suddenly being found by a
whole new category of people who didn't
know about you before and you don't know
what's involved no I wouldn't I wouldn't
I would he begin to recognize that my
goodness I think I've personally I can
probably personally claim to have you
know produced 50% of AOL's new users in
the past year I wouldn't say that at all
I think what's what's happening and and
the part that's grotesque I mean the UI
scare there's something that I see Bob
Kahn in the back of the room I mean I
see yes hi Bob
I mean you guys down in Washington seem
to have all your sign bits wrong you
know they you know because the fact not
you personally but the people who
surround you sort of the government I
mean the export laws on encryption are
mindless it guarantees us one thing only
the bad guys will have it the Senator
Exxon stuff is mindless because they
can't mean even if because you obviously
can't argue too hard against them
because you become a child pornographer
if you do but he can't that you can't
control it wasn't somebody tell him that
you know I'm I think government is going
to find it just in general the
nation-states gonna find less and less
of a role and it's already found less of
a role in the financial community and
it's going to just you know like all
things digital they seem to get bigger
and smaller at the same time and I think
you'll find that governance will get
smaller and more local and more global
at the same time
bark Bernstein a skate oh one of the
themes is especially in Bush 45 also in
Engelbart Nelson's original work was
augmentation liberation better people
and in the last year or two it seems
we've seen the unexpected side effect
come to roost laws that a transgression
is worse if you're carrying a gun or do
it with the computer is lords of work
worse well far for example pornography
is bad but pornography with the aid of
the computer is worse
forget its own law right theft is bad
but computer theft
that's worse right trespassing is bad
right but trespassing on someone else's
computers and felony yeah now there's oh
and this seems to tie in with what you
were saying about the gulch the the
people who are too busy or otherwise not
tied in but since they are also the
people with the power yeah how do week
for a while for a while right how do we
keep them from stomping out the whole
process for a while because they can't
stomp out the whole process they can do
anything they want
and my favorite analogy and and and I
want to be very upfront I first heard
this from Mitch Resnick and then I
modified his stories but I I love the
story of the ducks flying south and that
there's some people that think the front
duck is leading which of course it isn't
my my variation of that story is that if
you go out and I don't recommend it but
if you go out and shoot the front duck
they'll all scatter and then they'll
come back together and there'll be
another front duck and it is not the
vice-president duck that became
president document okay
and and the people there people in
Washington who think that and the
internet works like the Ducks and until
people recognize that ducks flying south
and the behavior of the net are one in
the same and unless you shoot all the
Ducks you've got nothing and so there I
really it's it's like fighting against
HGTV because I which I did V&V medley
four years ago and I haven't spoken
about it I think it's just gonna die of
its own weight
okay the so-called grand alliance is
just gonna poop out it's gonna look like
a sort of yak dung in about two years
on its own accord and that's why the
same things gonna happen with the people
who were that they're just gonna
evaporate because they're just you know
shoot one or two Ducks ask you a
question about basically bits and atoms
atoms have the wonderful property that
they're accessible if I gain a book
right anyone can read a book where as
bits have to be interpreted and there's
an encoding and encoding some can
obsolete so as we go to a digital media
do what steps do you think we need to
take to make sure that it's accessible
to everyone both during one time here at
and for future generations where the
encoding changes well the future
generation parts separate in the sense
of how do you make how do you archive
the bits I mean you could you could
drill holes into lyrium or something
that loses a few angstroms a century and
then probably preserve the bits and in
many different ways but but in terms of
the the accessibility and a lot of
people told me you know hey smartass you
think it's so digital and yet you
publish a stupid paper book which isn't
even on the net okay and it's there
right and it's you know why it's not on
the net because I may be a smartass but
the publisher is a smarter ass and won't
let me put it on the net and it turns
out that the that the that the medium
right now - at least for that group that
slug in the middle the display device
they have is a book and one of our
biggest projects starting up at the
Media Lab is to make electronic paper
and we think we have a way of making a
pulp like medium
very high contrast ratio you can write
in parallel you basically bind a hundred
pages of this stuff into something that
look like a book you write it over 20
minutes get again the contrast ratio of
paper when you're finished you plug it
back in it sucks the bits out it takes
away the thing and then you write it
again and if we can pull that off we'll
actually have in a few years damn thing
that looks and feels like a book but it
believe it or not is erasable and
rewritable and so on so maybe that's an
interim technology so there are a lot of
bets you have to make along the way I
don't you know I'm not trying to ride on
one particular you know bits atoms you
know transducer okay give it to me hard
[Laughter]
this is the last question because it'll
be the bid okay it's very simple
two years ago new media magazine asked
me to interview and we interview you and
we had a very nice chat and I asked for
a definition of media and you got kind
of flustered and said you'd get back to
me yeah I just wondered if you have one
yes meteor is like air in the sense that
you don't notice it until it's missing
okay
and that's probably really what's the
common denominator because it's not see
one of the reasons and I get into
trouble when I say you know the message
is not the medium people really dump on
me especially Alan Kay who knows a lot
more about Marshall McLuhan than Aida's
will sort of you know give a very
sophisticated response to that but I I
really have come to conclusion that
whatever carries the bits and whether
you think the carrier is something that
has a message in it even though the bits
may be transcoding in the receiver which
is I don't think something
McLuhan had thought about that you could
actually transmit bits and that they
actually have no quote form until they
arrive at the receiver whereupon you
know they get transcoded into one form
or another is is really more again it's
really like air it's not it's not that
it's paper it's not that it's TV it's
not that it's a screen and so that it's
it really is the bits but it's what air
is to us so you've said what it's like
writes because you give it like it make
rephrase that as a definition could I
rephrase that as a definition media is
like air yeah okay the media is air
so so I wind them what so wind then yes
would be the the motion of bits in some
direction under pressure and weather
would be let's say the global InfoSphere
and in its turn and a fart will be a
fact
I think my times up
[Applause]
thanks very much Nick I think you did
wake us up all right photo op for five
minutes take a stretch break the rest of
you Raj Reddy is next with the speakers
come up front right away please Nick
really does have to leave it's a great
pleasure to welcome Raj ready to the
podium Raj is of course the ai's gurus
guru and he's best known for his
pioneering work in speech recognition he
just told me this morning a little
detail that I'd forgotten at the
sixty-eight fall joint computer
conference he competed head-to-head with
the mother of all demos and in a
parallel session presented CMU's
pioneering work on computers with hands
eyes and ears and he says just like Doug
is still working on his program of
research so is he and so is his school
he's Dean of the school of computer
science at Carnegie Mellon and that
includes not just the department of
computer science but also the Institute
for robotics and he's the Herbert a
Simon professor of computer science and
robotics he's won many awards I'll only
mention the Gama award and the
all-important Turing Award Turing Award
is the big one in our field as you know
he's also the only person that I know of
in computer science who has a legend on
air presented by President anita huh I
asked him to speak about an aspect of
Bush's writing that doesn't get much
press which is his musings on speech and
language understanding and other things
that are related to that the vocoder
and anything else that he wants to tell
us about Raj please
thank you thank you Andy and in reading
the paper of Bush and thinking about
what he must have been thinking it be it
was clear to me you know as you know he
was the Crown Prince of scientific
establishment in the 40s in this country
and he had many problems and the key
problem he faced was access to
information on demand and so he invented
the Memex and the idea of multimedia
databases based on the technologies of
the day that he could think of that the
theme of my talk is that problem is
still there with us and it'll be there
for 50 more years when we have the
hundredth anniversary Bush's famous
paper the second thing we want to keep
in mind is that time period between
about nineteen forty-five to fifty-five
was a very important period for the
intellectual ferment that it caused to
happen as a result of the digital
technology being born while Bush may not
have fully understood the implications
of digital technology Alan Turing who by
that time had already invented the
symbol processor enigma and decoded the
German encryption scheme and Simon and
Newell and Minsky and McCarthy were all
beginning to think about computer as a
symbol processor and how symbolic
processing would come to dominate
computation as a whole and that vision
is the thing I think that for us to kind
of important to go away with namely not
the specific details that Bush proposed
but the fact that he thought perhaps
there may be ways in which one can
capture multiple media rather see images
or speech or language and text and have
it available at your fingertips on
demand and so what I hope to do today is
to kind of quickly review the progress
in each of these fields and kind of give
you show you a videotape of the current
status as I see it and then spend a few
minutes talking about what the future
might hold in all of these areas the
other important link to to people like
Doug Engelbart here is what he was
looking for is a way of amplifying his
own epic capabilities human augmentation
what all of AI is about is about
enhancing the capabilities of the human
being
intelligence amplifier is the phrase
that has been used the question is what
are the kinds of things we as a
community can do that will make each of
us ten times a hundred times more
effective than in the things that we
need to do and we want to do then we can
physically be given our human
capabilities so those are the twin
themes human augmentation and multimedia
databases that I think are the central
theses of Bush's paper so if we look at
it he he proposes the capture of image
information of various types and I'd
like to review for you where we are in
that that includes capture storage
retrieval and processing in in some form
he wasn't quite sure how it might be
processed he proposed he had known about
the vocoder at that time Dudley had
already shown it and and he thought
perhaps it might be possible to begin to
use voice input both for annotations you
know these days we call it the talking
paper you can add electronic annotations
to your page and so paper which is won't
talk back it you can suddenly begin to
talk and things like that he was already
thinking about and the whole issue of
hyperlinks and hypertext and language
processing and text processing was in in
Italy connected with all of these ideas
and what he did not say and perhaps was
not even thinking about is the next
issue in information and demand I think
several people pointed out I think it
may be Bob Kahn and herb Simon put it
very succinctly and if you read the
recent scientific American there's a
quote from him we have a wealth of
information but poverty of human
attention the whole issue of future
multimedia databases is going to be not
simply providing information and demand
our data on demand but getting the
relevant information in decision ready
form to the person that needs it people
that manage that transformation and have
those kinds of tools at their fingertips
would be a hundred thousand times more
effective than the rest of us who don't
have those tools and that is the key of
human augmentation in some sense so
where are we in each of these
technologies so any image processing I
kind of first got introduced image
processing when Marvin Minsky came to
Stanford in 64 and in our our own hubris
in AI we thought we could create a Mars
rover that we could put on the planet
Mars in 10 years and
Marvin and John McCarthy thought we
could do it in three years so we started
interfacing an image input device to the
PDP six I think it was and so the the
fact that you could actually transmit
image images or information was known
even to borscht but the fact you could
capture them in digital form was already
practical in the early 60s although very
painfully but only last year it became
possible to capture full video in for
hours on end and put it on a desk and
until we got a card that could plug into
your PC or workstation which would do
MPEG compression in real time it was not
practical it was very painful to get any
kind of moving data so we had we had to
wait almost thirty years to get the it
was you could always capture a
particular picture but capturing moving
scenes was not practical until recently
so the so what we can do now routinely
and there's no magic to this we can
digitize compress store retrieve and
display images and that was primarily
the vision abortion what we cannot yet
do is what Michael was saying yesterday
about image interpretation that's not
quite true we can do some in fact we
have a van autonomous you know vehicle
which drove from Washington DC all the
way to San Diego and 98 percent of the
time it was able to interpret the images
it was seeing and draw by itself
whenever it got confused it beeped at
the driver and said sorry I'm confused
you better take over so the theme of AI
is kind of has been shown slowly
shifting from replacing the human being
are doing everything that a human being
can do completely autonomously to the
theme of human augmentation let us do
everything that we can do and if there
are five or ten percent that we don't
know how to do automatically let the
human being take care of it please wait
I'll call my master all right so that is
the team and so in image processing you
can do road navigation digital mapping
robotic vision people use that routinely
and there are all kinds of tricks they
have to do but the broad idea if I can
give someone any random sequence of
images and say interpret them completely
we would fail but if you said interpret
them 80% of the time and let the human
being annotate the rest of it I think it
is doable it's not being done because
ARPA hasn't provided the funding to do
it yet
but it's the kind of thing it's a
question of what is doable at any given
point in time so what I'd like to do is
show you the first videotape one in one
minute
and this tape essentially gives the
next-generation vision of a digital
camera a digital camera you can buy
these days from Canon and Kodak and
there's even a standard that's being
established so you can take digital
pictures what you could not do with the
old cameras and the new cameras is to
have a camera which will produce a
panoramic vision of a 360-degree vision
and Apple recently introduced a thing
called QuickTime we are where you could
stitch together images for virtual
reality purposes with the poor man's
virtual reality and so you can actually
turn around and as you turn around you
could see what you would see but the
problem with it was to take those
pictures you had to have a tripod and do
the whole picture very precisely on a
plane so that stitching could happen one
of our students went to Apple he was
working on 3d vision and the the
transformations you need if you didn't
want to have those restrictions or you
have image
with distortions that result from pan
and tilt and zoom so you have
translation and rotation and prospective
distortions and if you can actually
solve those problems and stitch together
multiple images to make a composite
image then suddenly you have a camera
which is currently not practical so I'd
like not like to show the video showing
a small part of this there's no audio on
this so he went to in San Francisco took
a whole bunch of pictures of different
kinds and using a PowerPC Power Mac he
was able to then stitch together all
these images and do the appropriate
perspective distortion transformations
so that you now have a 3d camera
panoramic camera panoramic digital
camera
it is the video it's these are all
homebrew video packages so some of these
are not as good as they could be so you
can see it's slowly adjusting itself and
doing appropriate transformations and
ultimately it stitches itself together
and so this is now a practical
technology that can be done using
today's workstations and of course this
is you know those of you who haven't
studied the problem image registration
has been a fundamental problem in
computer vision for 30 years in its
purest form if you have a thousand by a
thousand image you have a million pixels
if you have to register them with
another million pixels you have 10 to
the 12 operations each operation is a
correlation operation which easily takes
between a thousand to ten thousand
operations so to register two images in
it the brute force form you're talking
about 10 to the 15 10 to the 16
operations so a lot of work has been
done by many people both at MIT and
Stanford and CMU number of places to do
this registration issue and all kinds of
heuristics and tricks are used to do
that and and here it is the heuristic
it's using is the human being roughly
positions it where it s the idea is to
get the precise teaching of the images
ok so that's the current status of the
kind of video cameras and video input
that's possible using the today's
technology that ran over Bush may not
have thought about the second area I
want to talk about is the speech
recognition area here is one area where
ARPA had the foresight to continue
supporting at various levels for 30
years and almost all the areas we are
looking at but that Vannevar Bush wanted
speech image language retrieval all
kinds of things these are what I call
imprecise technologies they're never
going to be perfect
and you need to kind of continuously
keep the interesting thing of course is
when used by human beings human beings
are not perfect either but nevertheless
they have figured out how to use these
sources of information effectively to do
the job they want to do you know how
many of you can recognize all the faces
and retrieve the right face in this room
that you have met and and it's pretty
poor in fact it is dismal
and so the retrieval human retrieval
capabilities are pretty lousy so given
that the kinds of things we'll be able
to do with these systems is substantial
so speech processing is one of those
areas which is never going to be perfect
but nevertheless I think we are you know
at a stage where useful systems doing
useful things for average people is
possible and I'd like to show you my
next video tape what it is is use it is
a speaker independent unlimited
vocabulary dictation running on a pen
and alone Pentium Raja
p6 bobwhite II doing voice mail later
Sphinx 3 application it make sense sorry
I missed you last night
period
I had hoped to show you our latest
implementation of Sphinx before you left
period
as with our previous unlimited
vocabulary systems comma it is speaker
independent and continuous speech period
so when makes an error you just go type
it in or speak it in it's not a big deal
so expecting a system to be perfectly
the other right attitude to have
the error rate is on the order of 15 to
20 percent period and we believe this
will go down to about 5% in two to three
years on about the same kind of machine
which is a p6 it's like two hundred
myths machine and currently uses 64
megabytes and the memory capacity may be
somewhat lower clearly future
cracking about people with that kind of
capability using this type the system is
running standalone on a new Pentium Pro
period as you can see , it is pretty
close to real time period
as PC platforms become faster and more
affordable , we will continue to use all
our cycles at our disposal that's the
way you would take the secretary who
doesn't understand all the terminology
that you're speaking and also can't
write fast enough perhaps as sometimes
you can speak and make the correction
sometimes you type it in you try once
start speaking again that doesn't
recognize your type it in so there's
even a second to that our that our so
you could so ultimately you give up and
you type again so so that kind of gives
you an idea where we are from a
historical perspective you know we've
been working on it collectively as a
community for 30 years victor zue here
at MIT john mccool and others at BBN
people at s RI CMU AT&T and IBM have all
been contributing and we are at a stage
now where if you know Michael was
talking about precision and recall and
metrics the the ARPA community has
embraced that with the speech program
about ten years ago
we've been running metrics every year
and we have very precise measures of how
well we do and the best indication of
the progress of science in this area is
any one of us does something and we all
publish these papers and talk about it
the annual conferences within three
months or six months everybody else can
implement it and have it running so the
replication of results which is the
nature of a true science and the
scientific method is something that
happens in this area on a routine basis
these days which is very satisfying so
the next area I want to kind of go to is
the whole language processing area of
all of the areas both image and speech
language processing is still perhaps
that to me more challenging if I had to
rank order the difficulty speech is
probably the easiest spoken language of
course you have you know it's hard but
if you just take the speech part as you
assign seeing language is probably this
perhaps the most important technologies
for the next decade and it's somewhat
harder image processing and image
understanding is an order of magnitude
harder and probably will be another 20
years or 30 years before we get to the
right place and the impact it will have
to me appears to be less at this point
in time then the impact language
technologies will have the kinds of
applications that we are looking at they
are not question answering things we
tried in the 60s in language but more
importantly things like retrieval which
Michael talked about yesterday
understanding summarization translation
and a whole range of related things the
best way I can illustrate this is to
show you really learn in my next video
tape which is about multimedia databases
and then come back and talk about some
fundamental difficult problems in
language processing implementing the
Vannevar Bush revision would have can we
now show the next video tape please
this is part of the infirmity can I hear
the music of Mozart
[Music]
are there any portraits of Mozart
do you have anything on mulch our
childhood and this was because it was
highly talented before one of the most
extraordinary prodigies of all time
he was the infant prodigy and he could
play blindfold or he could play with a
cloth over the keys do you have a video
of a performance of Mozart
until this last generation that
knowledge of Mozart could only be found
here throughout history humankind has
placed the highest emphasis on recording
and preserving of information for
generations to come but with a digital
society we live in today's libraries are
becoming transform video or motion
pictures have become the preferred
method for this documentation of our
society yet there are a limited means to
access the footage sitting in the vaults
of our television and film studios
around the country until now with the
combined efforts of Carnegie Mellon's
research scientists and the video
experts at WQED Pittsburgh we are
developing in for media a multimedia
library system with the ability to bring
you information on demand this concept
of information on demand is a
revolutionary idea in accessing large
amounts of video resources and makes
infra media the most advanced retrieval
system under development today through
advancement software technologies infra
media is able to access hundreds of
hours of video footage and present short
segments of made the users needs this
unique function is being made possible
through technologies being developed at
Carnegie Mellon University these
technologies are integrated into an
intelligent search and indexing system
speech recognition natural language
processing and image understanding make
up these cooperating technologies first
and probably the most familiar use of
speech recognition is to allow the user
to access the entire system through
voice commands computers shall
transcript religion replace the old
but the cathedral is also a symbol of
continuity in Mexico CMU is given speech
recognition an entirely new dimension
when applied to any video footage speech
recognition software automatically
generates a transcript transcripts are
then searched for subjects requested by
the user
the first method by which infra media
gives you the information you need
searching the transcript may not always
be sufficient the subject matter may not
be referred to directly in the text this
is where our second cooperating
technology comes into the picture
natural language processing allows a
higher level of semantic understanding
than merely the actual text allowing the
computer to search on topics that may
only be inferred since this is a visual
medium the actual video image is
important to understanding the content
image understanding by analyzing each
picture frame the computer is given
another tool for searching video footage
this enables the user to search video
for shots with the same scenic
composition particular backgrounds such
as face or blue sky
[Music]
or searching on only footage with a
single person talking now let's take
these technologies and see how they
create the infirmity ax system in for
media can process any type of video
footage this footage is then broken down
into its video and audio tracks the
audio track is automatically transcribed
through speech recognition technology
the transcript is then indexed using
natural language processing technology
to give a comprehensive topical index
the video track is then segmented using
image understanding technology the video
is divided into useful sized clips and
automatically stored and indexed the two
tracks are then rejoined now in a useful
indexed multimedia library once online
users can search this multimedia library
through voice commands using speech
recognition the video is then presented
giving the user information on demand
for the commoners the Spanish conquest
and the later Mexican Revolution brought
merely an end to one form of government
and the imposition of another Carnegie
Mellon University and WQED Pittsburgh
are doing what's never been done before
creating vast explorable digital video
libraries for those who wish to see a
more extended demonstration of in for
media in action let the tape continue to
roll the current information system is
under development at carnegie
and possesses many of the functions and
applications the complete system will
eventually have
do you have anything on Mars the system
has a speaker independent speech
recognition interface to allow users to
enter their queries through voice
commands
the computer shows the results of the
search through these icons and titles
each of these icons represents a short
segment of a larger video enabling the
system to return only the information
you require and Star Trek The Next
Generation I've led many an expedition
in science fiction now as your host on
space age I will guide you through an
incredible real-life adventure the story
of how humans and machines have combined
to bring us to the brink of a new age of
discovery here are a few of the infra
media research scientists to demonstrate
the system's new functions and
applications hello I'm Alex Hoffman of
the Carnegie Mellon's speech recognition
Research Group speech recognition has
taken on a variety of other functions
within the information system
what about the bus that was bombed by
Muslim fundamentalists in Israel
speech recognition can automatically
generate transcripts from the audio
tracks with this transcript is then time
synced to the video to allow the word
following
[Music]
a tower covered a decapitated corpse her
I'm a quid pro from Carnegie Mellon
University's computer science department
a recent development in infamy dia is
his application for media news on demand
with M familia news on demand a user has
access to a library of recent news
stories from around the globe
what do you have about a tank in San
Diego in for media news on demand can
access news information from broadcast
radio and why new services giving the
user a wider variety of perspectives
than any single source correspondent
Reid Galen has the story and incredible
pictures 58 tons of war machine on a
rampage in San Diego there have been
many recent developments in the way our
users can access the video footage
tell me about the new Microsoft Windows
operating system the first development
is the use of skins for reviewing the
video segments at compression rates of
up to 20 times real time the user can
quickly access the main ideas of the
segment this professor says Microsoft
has heiped game retailers to find an
exact location within a video segment we
have created video film strips these
markers indicate the exact location in
the footage where the query topic is
mentioned
what is it windows 95 is an operating
system which is the basic software the
controls personal computer we have
developed another kind of skin with a
lower compression rate that focuses on
the content of the video
International States University
in Familia students are automatically
generated using statistical language
versus a 30/70 students train for
tomorrow's challenges in space
artificial G's you get to sleep in
cubicles I would like to think that
we're coming into a new age space is for
commercialization whole generation is
arisen instant information
digitized indexed
searched
[Music]
retrieved
it's the age of infirmity ax so what I'd
like to kind of do is it all looks kind
of sexy and glitzy but there are there
are a lot of interesting solutions and
also lots of interesting research
problems I'd like to share with you some
of the interesting research problems
first I want to tell you about the
problems in language processing so let
us look at two kinds of information
retrieval problems one is that I serve
as a commodity trader and I said give me
all the stories about gold it is
possible that I might also be interested
in getting other stories about pressure
precious metals like platinum or uranium
or whatever on the other hand I don't
want stories about golden parachute or
American Express gold card so that
requires what I think Doug was talking
about yesterday of semantically based
retrieval systems there's a different
kind of associative retrieval that's
also important which we don't fully know
how to do yet
supposing I asked a news story saying do
you have any news clips of art rasa teas
in Banja Luka perhaps you might have it
but an intelligent retrieval system
might also want to say would you like
stories about that in garage de you know
and that requires understanding of
geography and the fact these two cities
our towns are in the same geographical
region in Bosnia and the fact your
interest in one might also imply that
your interesting stories in the other
one we are not anywhere close to that
kind of thing but we will get there five
10 15 years probably hopefully before
the retirement that Michael was talking
about even when we get there we will
never be perfect but given the fact the
human retrieval systems are pretty lousy
themselves we will be very happy to use
whatever we can get the only indications
of these that you look at the lake house
and you
and other systems which are Internet
catalogs they're not that good but the
last I looked every day more than
100,000 people log into Lycos catalog
index just to find out where they can
find other related information for many
people it is the way of doing business
every day today and it fits Michaels
test saying if I can if I try to take it
away and you complain bitterly then the
technology has arrived and and the same
is true is going to be true for speech
or language or vision if we can build
applications that normal people can
routinely use in spite of the fact there
will be full of errors full of errors is
a proportional term a relative term and
we just need to kind of have metrics
which will help us to determine at what
point something is ready for primetime
and so let me give you some other facts
about the dipper all the news stories
you saw there were picked right off of
the airwaves and fully completely
automatically indexed that speech
recognition transcripts were fully
produced automatically I don't want you
to think they were perfect far from it
they were the error rate there in most
of those transcripts
he's about of the order about twenty
percent if you simply didn't have a lot
of the shortcuts we're using for example
in order to produce the transcript we
not only use the language model from all
the news stories of 1994 we have a thing
called LM toujours the language model of
the day which picks off all the news
stories of the day and it also uses the
closed caption data which is roughly
about 70% correct and the trick here is
not just to produce the transcript but
also align the video and audio and text
which is the Ted's transclusion problem
of relating all the related things that
are the same in multiple media
and I'm doing it in a way that is useful
on a routine basis the image
segmentation you find you know the
problem of aligning the new story with
the image segmentation is something we
don't know how to do either and we do it
many times it is off by half a second or
a second so you get a little incorrect
strip at the beginning or at the end you
lose something and people don't seem to
mind so the issue here is how do we
create technologies that are imperfect
in themselves in precising themselves
but nevertheless useful to a human being
in the human augmentation sense let me
give you a couple of other language
problems not none retrieval typing
language you saw we were when you clip
when you click on an icon it was showing
your headline that is intended to be a
newspaper headline story of that story
so given a hundred words or 200 words
how do you produce a five word headline
out of it we don't know how to do it
right but whatever we're doing is better
than not having it at all and again we
don't have good metrics for defining
what constitutes a high-quality headline
the second thing you saw is the skin is
essentially semantic fast-forward you
know if you have to use the conventional
VCR type of fast-forward you just see
the image but you won't hear anything
and whatever you here would not be
coherent the whole idea here is can you
see a two-hour lecture or a two-hour
movie in five minutes and then decide
well you're going to listen to the rest
of it afterwards if we could do that we
would have increased most of our
productivity by a factor of ten or so
that's true human augmentation of in the
sense of that so there are a number of
potential leapfrogs
that would happen as we begin to build
on these technologies and what I'd like
to do now is to show you look into the
future
of what some of the things we're doing
at CMU this kind of relates to 3d
photography and 3d imaging and how that
might transform the way we do things in
the future
can I next show the last videotape
please
at carnegie-mellon robotics Institute we
have made substantial progress in 3d
computer vision and working on its new
applications we have built a video rate
stereo machine that can produce a
complete dense depth map of a scene at
30 frames per second aligned with
intensity images probably the first of
its kind a 5 camera stereo head is used
to image a scene this is the intensity
image the machine processes multiple
image data from five cameras based on
the multi baseline stereo theory and
computes depth for each pixel in the
depth image shown here brighter pixels
indicate closer points the darker the
pixel the farther from the camera we can
observe the video rate operation the
size of the depth image is up to 254 by
240 the depth resolution is currently 5
bits an increase to 7 bits is being
planned the capability of obtaining
dense 3d distance and shaping formation
at video rate opens up a new class of
applications one of them is what we
named Zeki a new technique for merging
real and virtual images chroma key is a
standard technique for image
superimposition such as a TV reporter in
front of a weather map unlike the chroma
key that uses blue color as the key to
switch between the real and virtual
scenes the z key compares depth
information from the stereo machine and
the Z buffer from the graphic system for
switching as a result a real person can
be between the two virtual lamps are
partially in front of and behind the
virtual object
we can also have the virtual object
interact with the real object
consistently here the virtual lamp is
casting a shadow on the person with the
correct shape as he moves note the
person is also casting a shadow onto the
virtual wall another project that we are
working on is the virtualized reality
studio that can turn a real-world event
into a virtual one by using 3d computer
vision and graphics tools the goal is to
immerse the user into a reconstruction
of a real world event completely
interactively the virtualized reality
Studio dome is fully covered by many
cameras from all directions in this
example we used cameras located on one
half of the dome and recorded a scene on
two videotapes the range or depth of
every point in an image was computed
using the same multi baseline stereo
algorithm used in the video rate stereo
machine but offline the depth map is
edited to focus on the region of
interest the scene can be reconstructed
with the depth and intensity information
by placing a virtual or soft camera from
the front from the left from the right
or from the top
or moving the soft camera as the user
moves freely earlier results of the
virtualized to reality studio dealt with
moving scenes the event originally
observed from a single viewpoint can be
viewed from many angles or even moving
viewpoints from the left close-up from
above to below and from the left trying
to steal the ball for this baseball
scene we can create a balls eye view it
is our intention to develop a full video
rate system using the video rate stereo
technology virtualized reality has great
significance in training telepresence
and entertainment in that it would
enable users to interact with real event
or performance from dynamically selected
via point so Takeya kannadi whom you saw
there is the director of the robotics
Institute he's too modest to fully hype
the potential of this technology but I
am NOT so I'll tell you about that
basically what you're seeing here is the
beginnings of teleportation and
telepresence and Telep time travel okay
I'm not joking the teleportation idea is
supposing you want it to be at the
Mariners game that rent for 11 innings
and hour and you're but you're in Boston
you can place yourself right next to the
batter and see exactly what he's seeing
with this technology so that's not quite
teleportation of Star Trek that is you
cannot change physically anything that's
going on in the baseball game but you
can position yourself at that place
the same technology begins to show us
what time travel might be like those of
you who are neither we've got in need of
an O J fix and want to somehow go back
and relive what Oh J was doing you could
sit right next to him put yourself back
two weeks or three weeks sit right next
to him and see what he was seeing when a
witness was actually saying something
about him more importantly if this
technology were available in 1945 you
would have been able to sit right next
to our 1944 Churchill Stalin and
Roosevelt and see what they were saying
and seeing and what they were saying
in the same kind of read so it's not
quite time travel into the future but
it's at least time travel into the past
and you can't change the past so in that
sense we are beginning to see the
beginnings of what you might call in
teleportation and time-travel and each
of these images takes about 50 billion
operations to produce a 3d map and so we
are we can use up all the cycles that
anybody can produce for a long time to
come and you can expect when we have our
100th anniversary of this almost all the
domes Houston dome and everything else
will have a few thousand cameras so
those of us couch potatoes can have any
kind of a seat we want from anywhere in
the stadium okay so with that I'd like
to conclude let me kind of for me the
lessons of borscht are kind of three
fault
first the vision of information and
demand I think is still very important
and in particular in access to relevant
information rapidly in decision ready
form it's a fundamental technology set
of involves a number of fundamental
technologies which we don't know how to
solve
which were all still extremely important
and when we solve even the solve these
problems even partially the increase in
human augmentation and intelligence
amplification are if we don't want to
use those you know hype words simply
productivity enhancement if you could do
the things you do by a factor of five or
ten or a hundred then you are
essentially creating a superhuman race
on the planet those of you who have
these tools will be 100 times more
effective in whatever it is that you're
trying to do and in that sense Bush's
vision is still extremely important
there are a number of very interesting
technical problems which are all seem to
be solvable they will never be solved
perfectly but that's okay the second
important lesson out of all of this is
the important the implications of the
whole technology of multimedia databases
and information and demand is for
socialization of knowledge it's no
longer the case
a few mandarins who have access to the
right information can sit in a corner
and decide all these things everyone in
the world will have access to the same
information even those who are
illiterate and poor and perhaps don't
even know how to type a read can have
access to this information that's an
amazing amazing prospect and the third
is what Anna Bob Kahn called D fixation
yesterday I love that word each of you
can capture everything you have ever
said in your entire life in about a
terabyte of information today using the
new CD discs is about 200 desks in 20
years from now I bet it'll be about 20
disks with the density is increasing and
it might even be one desk because things
in
technology is moving very fast and
that's not very many discs so if you
have the appropriate kind of retrieval
thing all the way from your baby babble
to the time of your profound
pronouncements when you're 80
everything can be captured and you can
access access to all of that you know
forever so everything you've said you
can also have access to everything you
have done from a 3d sense okay it's only
a thousand times more I've did the
calculation on the bits the D fixation
of everything you've done is about a
petabyte and if you again say how many
discs is that projecting into the future
it's about about a thousand discs of a
terabyte each CDs of this science and
that will fit in a shoebox and so when
you die they can burry your shoebox
desks of everything you've done it's too
bad Negroponte is gone but I have to
request Alan Kay instead perhaps one of
you would write a book called being
immortal this is it you know the way you
become immortal is to capture everything
you've ever done and worry it with you
so in future if somebody wants to know
what you've done you can do it and when
we figure out how to do simulated
evolution you can create a clone of you
so that that person does the same things
in the future thank you
[Applause]
terrific rush okay folks keep them busy
yes sir
dick Marcus MIT you said that in order
to do really smart information retrieval
we're going to need some sophisticated
natural language processing techniques
at least yes more but I'd like to
suggest that we can already do
sophisticated information retrieval and
perhaps what you're saying is that to do
it completely automatically if we go
back to what
Vannevar Bush was doing he was talking
about interactive systems in which the
intelligence of the human works in
conjunction with the mechanical things
and I would suggest that if we look at
the same paradigm today that we do have
expert searchers who do quite effective
information retrieval and some of us are
working on research to show that if we
have automated expert assistance we can
achieve the same kind of expertise even
now okay I'm a big proponent of that in
fact within when I give talks to my AI
colleagues I say we should be working on
8020 systems let us do the 80% that can
be done routinely and if we can also
make this system so that they can say I
don't know the answer to this please
rate I'll call my supervisor which is a
human being and that person can do the
remaining 20% and then those of us in AI
research will look over your shoulder
and say what is it that you're doing for
the 20% and apply the 80/20 rule to that
hopefully in under 10 years we would be
at 96% level so that's I think exactly
the right paradigm
I'm Bob Kahn Irish I found the the
example that you gave of the interplay
between the reality world and the
digital world very compelling and I'd
like to take it one step further by
asking you to speculate a bit I mean you
had the example on the screen of was a
Takaoka naughty and lamp land and you
know on the other hand you might have my
guess Roger Rabbit in the dean's office
is the other example the interactions
that you're talking about there are
extremely static even though there is
some motion and a little bit of dynamics
but you can't really get any interplay
where one thing affects the other in
those examples so if you were to take
your example of Roger Eddie in the ball
park in Seattle could you imagine that
you could be at the batter's plate and
actually not replace the batter to do
what he did but in fact get up against
the picture in simulation land and see
what you could have done to effect the
change or maybe practice playing right
field how how much can you see in terms
of real dynamic non-causal interaction
taking place in this in the center plane
there that's a great question
there I have three vignettes I want to
share with you about that one is what
we're working on a thing called video
karaoke which is something like that but
we we had a piece on the and the in
familiar tape which we took out for lack
of time the way we started on that whole
project was about four years ago we
discovered there are hundred hours of
interviews with Arthur Clarke in WQED
archives they only used four minutes of
it and I said this is crazy isn't there
some way we can capture all of those
things and then kind of find out what he
had to say and one of the students did
something very brilliant I thought once
you capture
and have a complete text of the
transcript of the whole thing you can
ask any question that comes to your mind
and interact with Arthur Clarke and you
will give you the answer you know it
goes right to that particular phrase
where he used the same phrase that you
had in your question and then start
answering something and you would think
he's answering you he's not it tell so
happened that phrase occurred in some
context and and it's a synthetic
interview you know it's kind of another
example of the kind of interaction the
best ones I know of this kind are is the
work of Joe Bates who is working on
interactive drama and interactive
friction and and interactive agents all
of it at a and and Joe is the kind of
leading proponent within AI community
building these agents like a fish or a
Roger Rabbit or somebody who would come
and talk to you and talking to interact
with you and you could play a game
together or do whatever and the whole
spectrum of interactive fiction and
interactive drummond is is going to be
there and it'll be fun to watch
Ted
just one point about about transclusion
the-the-the the term you referred to
resolving a number of tapes and and and
concurrent and coordinated materials I
prefer the term resolution for that
transclusion means precisely the reuse
of the same bits in a different context
as labels thank you
I rush and Moriarty MIT a lot of people
tend to get a little camera-shy in
general if you just take a camera
pointed at them you all of a sudden no
longer have the real-life event you have
people playing to the camera or somehow
altering reality because of the fact
you're putting a camera or somehow
recording and if we took this thought to
a 50 year extreme I'm really curious
we have people no longer needed for
remembering things so your brain doesn't
need to do that and we have the
technology potentially becoming kind of
the entire environment in which people
are playing and I'm really curious what
the impact could be in sort of an
insidious way just the impact on what is
a person at that point what is our role
and can you just talk about this it's
mad side the dark side yeah
the I don't see any dark side at all in
fact no matter what people will be
thinking because the bits will be
constantly churning and it's kind of the
nature of the human race our human
species see when we felt called we
didn't wait till genetics to grow fur on
our body we made her fur coats you know
when you know we wanted to fly we didn't
wait to have wings you know we made
airplanes when we want to remember and
think we will make our artifacts and use
them as an augmentation device and that
is the way it'll all happen and the
human being will be at the center of
everything there's no way you know I
would argue would anybody would stop
thinking even an illiterate person in a
little village I come from it is not
going to be the case
yeah Allen actually I have a different
answer the question which is it always
reminds me of that wonderful cartoon of
the classroom in which the professor's
tape recorder is talking to all the
student tape recorders and both the
professor and the students are off doing
something more worthwhile so one of the
ways of thinking about this is this is
the answer to the problem of Moore's law
which is how can you get computers to
use up all their capacity answer is
we'll have them talk to each other right
and meanwhile we'll go off and do
something useful because the other way
of getting remembered forever is to have
just one good idea not to have a shoebox
full of all your trivial ones right so I
kind of like that old way better okay
thanks again Raj that was great
[Applause]
you